boastful speeches are the first sign of
weakness
and those who are capable of great
things keep their mouths shut
[Music]
the thing's hardest to Bear are sweetest
to remember
someone despises me
that's their problem
we are more often frightened than hurt
and we suffer more from imagination than
from reality
the first rule is to keep an untroubled
spirit
the second is to look things in the face
and know them for what they are
a gem cannot be polished without
friction
nor a man perfected without trials
we should not like sheep follow the herd
of creatures in front of us
making our way where others go not where
we ought to go
we all love ourselves more than other
people
but care more about their opinion than
our own
you have power over your mind
not outside events
realize this and you will find strength
a man who suffers before it is necessary
suffers more than is necessary
be tolerant with others and strict with
yourself
it is not by muscle speed or physical
dexterity that great things are achieved
but by reflection
force of character in judgment
if it's endurable then endure it
stop complaining
anger if not restrained is frequently
more hurtful to us than the injury that
provokes it
your enemies can kill you but only your
friends can hurt you
the object of life is not to be on the
side of the majority
but to escape finding oneself in the
ranks of the insane
to Bear trials with a Calm Mind Rob's
Misfortune of its strength and burden
get busy with life's purpose toss aside
empty hopes
get active in your own rescue
no person hands out their money to
passerby
but to how many do each of us hand out
our lives
we're tight-fisted with property and
money
yet think too little of wasting time
the one thing about which we should all
be the toughest misers
stop allowing your mind to be a Slave
to be jerked about by selfish impulses
to kick against fate in the present
and to mistrust the future
our plans miscarry because they have no
aim
when a man does not know what Harbor he
is making for
no wind is the favorable wind
ask yourself at every moment
is this necessary
most powerful is he who as himself in
his own power
life is very short and anxious for those
who forget the past neglect the present
and Fear the Future
life if well lived is long enough
it is not death that a man should fear
but he should fear never beginning to
live
[Music]
be wary of the man who urges an action
in which he himself incurs no risk
the best revenge is to be unlike him who
performed the injury
no evil propensity of the human heart is
so powerful that it may not be subdued
by discipline
if it is not right do not do it
if it is not true
do not say it
there is never any need to get worked up
or to trouble your soul about things you
can't control
these things are not asking to be judged
by you
leave them alone
true happiness is to enjoy the present
without anxious dependence upon the
future
the mind that is anxious about the
future is miserable
why should you feel anger at the world
as if the world would notice
when you arise in the morning think of
what a privilege it is to be alive
to think to enjoy
to love
difficulties strengthen the mind as
labor does the body
be like the cliff against which the
waves continually break
but it stands firm and tames the fury of
the water around it
the greatest remedy for anger is delay
no man can escape his destiny
the next inquiry being how he may best
live the time that he has to live
if you are distressed by anything
external
the pain is not due to the thing itself
but to your estimate of it
and this you have the power to revoke at
any moment
time discovers truth
how much more damage anger and grief do
than the things that cause them
as long as you live keep learning how to
live
receive without conceit release without
struggle
The Art of Living is more like wrestling
than dancing
because an Artful life requires being
prepared to meet and withstand sudden
and unexpected attacks
if you are distressed by anything
external the pain is not due to the
thing itself
but to your estimate of it
in this you have the power to revoke at
any moment
everything we hear is an opinion not a
fact
everything we see is a perspective not
the truth
because the thing seems difficult for
you
do not think it impossible for anyone to
accomplish
luck is what happens when preparation
meets opportunity
waste no more time arguing about what a
good man should be
one
your days are numbered use them to throw
open the windows of your soul to the Sun
if you do not
the sun will soon set
and you with it
life's like a play it's not the length
but the Excellence of the acting then
matters
think of yourself as dead
you have lived your life now take what's
left and live it properly
all cruelty Springs from weakness
here is a rule to remember in future
when anything tempts you to feel better
not this is Misfortune but
to bear this worthily is good fortune
the impediment to action advances action
what stands in the way becomes the way
do not indulge in dreams of having what
you have not
but reckon up the chief of the blessings
you do possess
and then thankfully remember how you
would crave for them if they were not
yours
whoever does wrong wrongs himself
whoever does injustice
does it to himself
making himself evil
nowhere can man find a quieter or more
untroubled retreat
than in his own soul
silence is a lesson learned through
life's many sufferings
we live only now
everything else is either past
or is unknown
a person's worth is measured by the
worth of what he values
the things you think about determine the
quality of your mind
your soul takes on the color of your
thoughts
confine yourself to the present
choose not to be harmed and you won't
feel harmed
don't feel harmed
and you haven't been
humans have come into being for the sake
of each other
so either teach them or learn to Bear
them
very little is needed to make a happy
life
it is all within yourself in your way of
thinking
[Music]
if you like being alone it's a sign that
you have inner strength and independent
thinking
a man who likes being alone has more
ability to appreciate moments of
solitude to enjoy the Simplicity of life
the bravest sight in the world is to see
a great man struggling against adversity
while we are postponing
life speeds by
you are lonely not because no one needs
you
but because you care about who is next
to you
do not act as if you were going to live
Ten Thousand Years
death hangs over you
while you live while it is in your power
be good
do Every Act of your life as though it
were the very last Act of your life
the more honest men are the less he
suspects others of dishonesty
a low soul always presupposes the lowest
motives for Noble Deeds
ignorance is the cause of fear
whenever you are about to find fault
with someone ask yourself the following
question
What fault of mine most nearly resembles
the one I'm about to criticize
dig Within
within is the Wellspring of good and it
is always ready to Bubble Up
if you just dig
reject your sense of injury and the
injury itself disappears
except whatever comes to you woven in
the pattern of your destiny
for what could more aptly fit your needs
it is a rough road that leads to the
heights of greatness